في تركيا وبعد طول انتظار وتكهنات اعلن
المرشح الخاسر في الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والملقب بصانع الملوك
سنان اوغان انه سيدعم الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان في جوله الحسن من الانتخابات
والتي سيتنافس فيها الاخير مع مرشح
المعارضه كمالك في الثامن والعشرين من
مايو جريح اوغان اوضح ان قرار دعم اردوغان
جاء بعد التشاوري مع قاده التحالف الاجداد
الذي مثله في الانتخابات واضاف ان
المعارضه التركيه لم تقدم له اسبابا مقنعه
لكي يدعم مرشحها في الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات وغانا الذي حصل على 5% من
الاصوات في الجوله السابقه يعول عليه
اردوغان لحسم السباق لصالحه
[موسيقى]
اعلن اننا سندعم السيد رجب طيب اردوغان
مرشح الرئاسه عن تحالف الشعب في الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات ادعو كل الناخبين
الذين صوتوا لنا في الجوله الاولى لدعم
السيد اردوغان في جوله الاعاده فشل تحالف
الامه في تحقيق النجاح الكافي ضد تحالف
الشعب الذي يتولى السلطه منذ 20 عاما كما
انهم لم يتمكنوا من تقديم منظور يقنعنا
بالمستقبل والاهم انهم فشلوا في تامين
الاغلبيه البرلمانيه وتجاهلت عامل
الاستقرار لمتابعه
المزيد لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات